how's it go predators today we're
playing sure sweet unbuttoned see I
learned I learned from lifestyle I
learned from my mistakes
apparently not because I'm playing this
[ __ ] again we beat level one we
destroyed level two and now we're gonna
anally roller skate level three I have
full faith in that we can complete this
without breaking a sweat
I'm already sweating wake up in the
morning new day a new challenge for me
to fail at god dammit what ah I'm fine
fine who keeps their bread by their
bedside table a soon epic jump didn't
really go as planned is really a
climbing game this is more than anything
this is a game about climbing ha yeah
Wow what's up that's how we climb in
Sweden [ __ ] ah no we're fine ok we're
gonna go up there we're gonna grab the
skateboard we're gonna 360 no-scope and
then we're gonna toast
why break every bone in my body
mamma bread would be proud of you she
saw you today what the [ __ ] is this
plant doing ah
what the [ __ ] do I do now I'm so dead
never give up
follow your dreams this game is so
inspirational rah rah we can do it wake
it up
come on he thought I was a bread no I'm
a spider I don't know
buy the bread spider braids we're almost
there [ __ ] uh mister uh
yeah yeah that's right he stalks his
prey and he becomes ready to make a leap
of faith ah what way my I can't touch
this is this it
yeah it Woolies dirty [ __ ] scumbag
house owner Jesus Christ oh look there's
old moldy and [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
disgusting [ __ ] lives in this house
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
don't fight me Kat black black
what are you blood yeah ah what what ah
it begs pranks it Birds
oh we did it plant you son of a [ __ ]
I thought we were friends did you see
that that was ah ah you distracted me ah
glad you saved my life
plant thank you now welcome pets I love
you
I'm a monkey bread that's what I am a
monkey bake this bread that would
actually make a lot of sense I'm just
gonna assume the iron board is on
alright here we comes it for play poor
defeated smellin d40 femme de Scottie we
poured a quitter
male er ha ha ha I'm I'm dripping I'm
dripping in sweat
this game is gonna be the death of me
look at that [ __ ]
glorious who keeps their skateboard on a
shelf what kind of psychopath does these
deeds oh can we toast our self in this
woman no no that's yeah we are we
awesome slide in just slide in that hole
slide in baby slide in slide in baby you
got it you got it you got it you're a
man your man is what do you [ __ ] you
then oh oh oh so close oh yes yes sweet
toast sweet okay now we just have to
hump it now we just have to help you let
me love what are you doing
just let it let it burn
No aah oh hello all right I'll take it
that looks great
shut up ah [ __ ] yeah all right thank you
for us watching hit the like button if
you enjoyed and want to see more and let
me know and as always stay awesome
breasts and sloughing in heart Leone's
butter yeah yeah